hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
why does Camus title his early essay the
myth of Sisyphus why make that character
out of Greek mythology who we don't
actually know that much about so central
to the condition of modern humanity in
the 20th and 21st century well because
as he tells us Sisyphus is a good
example of the absurd hero not the only
possible example mind you become who
will discuss others within the course of
this work and depict many others in his
own novels and plays but Sisyphus offers
us a kind of centering point and if we
look at his example and what the myth is
supposed to do we understand
cow Moos position on the absurd and
whether in fact we can find meaning and
be happy to any degree within a human
condition and universe marked by
absurdity so first of all who who was
this guy if you haven't done a lot of
reading and Greek mythology you probably
only know about his punishment of
rolling this boulder up the hill almost
endlessly it gets to the
and then the boulder rolls back down to
the bottom of the hill with a big crash
and he's got to go down the hill and
start doing it again you've probably
seen lots of memes and other images of a
big guy with his back into the work
pushing this giant boulder up the hill
and that's part of the story but that's
really the near end point of the story
so why were the gods condemning this
this hero to begin with
he's a larger-than-life figure and Camus
tells us that according to some
traditions Sisyphus was the wisest and
most prudent of mortals but according to
another tradition he was disposed to
practice the profession of highwaymen
and so instead of saying well which one
is it Camus says I have no problem
believing that he did both why because
he's one of the boldest people around
which is you know the highwayman and he
also has a certain kind of wisdom so why
did the gods condemn him Camus says he's
accused of a certain levity in regard to
the gods he stole their secrets one
example
Aegina the daughter of a simple is
carried off by Jupiter the father was
shocked by that disappearance and
complained to Sisyphus he who knew the
of the abduction offered a tell about it
on the condition that a sophist would
give water to the Citadel of Corinth so
he's producing a political action in
order to deal with a divine abduction he
says Homer tells us that Sisyphus had
put death in Chains Pluto could not
endure the sight of his deserted silent
Empire he dispatched the God of War who
liberated death from the hands of her
Conqueror another crazy thing he does
being near to death he wants to test his
wife's love he orders her to cast his
unburied body into the middle of the
public square which for the ancient
Greeks would be a really big problem
because it means your ghosts because
you're not properly buried is going to
wander around right the public square is
not the place for that
you should have proper funeral
ceremonies so he wakes up in the
underworld and no
by an obedience so contrary to human
love he obtains from Pluto permission to
return to Earth to chastise his wife but
then the story gets gets better right he
gets back to earth and he forgets his
mission because he likes being alive so
much as Camus says he enjoyed water and
Sun warm stones in the sea and he no
longer wanted to go back to the infernal
darkness they sent him a lot of recall
signs of anger and warnings he lived
years and then a decree of the Gods is
necessary
mercury comes seizes him by the collar
and leads him back to the underworld so
he is clearly a guy who doesn't take the
gods as seriously as they would like to
be taken and he's different than other
human beings at the time in that respect
so what is his punishment as Camus is
going to tell us it's a task of futile
and hopeless labor why is it futile well
because he's pushing this this rock up
to you know the top of an apex on a
mountain where it's just gonna fall down
again
there's nothing achieved in this there's
nothing attained it's just moving stuff
around it's sort of like those make-work
jobs where you dig a hole in one place
and put the dirt in another place and
then you know dig another hole put the
dirt from the first hole in the second
hole and then just keep going around
like musical chairs well you know that
is a futile task and it's hopeless he's
never going to escape from it this is
his fate for the rest of eternity and
interestingly enough Camus calls
Sisyphus the proletarian of the gods
he's the one who's doing the labor but
it's it's futile labor it's it's
worthless labor now why look at this
story Camus tells us that myths are made
for the imagination to breathe life into
them and so what does that mean we use
our imagination to put ourselves perhaps
in the place of a spectator watching
Sisyphus or perhaps
in the place of Sisyphus himself maybe
we even put ourselves in the place of
one of the gods seeing whether we derive
any satisfaction from this this
vengeance that they've imposed upon him
and by doing so by imagining what it's
like we come to understand not just the
story better but also our own human
condition where we can recognize that we
often have our own Sisyphean tasks of
rolling boulders doing things that seem
futile and hopeless so he says as for
this myth one sees merely the whole
effort of a body straining to raise the
huge stone to roll it and push it up a
slope a hundred times over you see the
face screwed up the cheek tight against
the stone the shoulder bracing the clay
covered mass the foot wedging and the
fresh start with arms outstretched the
holy human security of to earth clotted
hands then we see the stone at the the
top rolling back down again and we see
Sisyphus lumbering his way back down to
the stone why is Sisyphus and an absurd
hero as Camus is going to tell us well
there's several reasons there's a
wonderful phrase here he is a tragic
hero as much through his passions not a
tragic hero an absurd hero as much
through his passions as he is through
his suffering or torture so it's not
just what's being imposed upon him it's
not just oh life sucks man everything's
against me it's also what he feels and
what he does that makes him a hero
rather than just a victim and so this is
something that Camus thinks is very
important for understanding what we
could call an ethics of the absurd why
is he tragic he's tragic as Camus tells
us because he's conscious because he
knows that this is a stupid job you know
a dung beetle pushes a big ball around
and there's not a hell of a lot of point
to that other than it likes dong right
somebody will probably add you know all
sorts of other functions to this
and within an echo system yes there's a
whole point of dung beetles but follow
me along here a dung beetle doesn't
think to itself man I could be doing
something different than this this is a
task that is beneath me remember
Sisyphus had been a king right he had
been a very wise person he was able to
trick the gods at one point or another
so clearly his talents are not being
well used right maybe it in hell he
should have been put in charge of like
tallying up the souls or you know law
clerking for my nose and Rhadamanthus or
something like that that would have used
his intelligence more no here he's
turned into a brute beasts of burden who
knows that he's something more than that
now think about the situation of so many
people trapped in conditions in our
contemporary existence where they know
that they're more than just what it is
that they've been assigned to do and yet
unless things you know somehow align
well they're going to be stuck in that
position if not for eternity at least
for a very long time what else makes the
surface a absurd hero come who signals
the scorn of the gods hatred of death
and passion for life these are the
things that go to the core of this
character Sisyphus he doesn't take what
the gods have to say as being
determinative he's going to make his own
way and he'll suffer because of it he
hates death he's unwilling to stay down
in the underworld and you know make do
and say oh well I had my chance passion
for life once he makes his way out of
the underworld and gets back to the
world he is not going to let it go any
time early he's certainly not going to
commit suicide now Camus also has some
important reflections here about
happiness and the absurd and he tells us
that happiness and the absurd are two
suns of the same earth they are
inseparable now he cautions us he says
it would be a mistake
say that happiness necessarily Springs
from the absurd discovery it happens as
well that the feeling of the absurd
Springs from happiness so sometimes you
know we can encounter the absurdity it
doesn't actually make us happy and even
within our moments of happiness we can
be you know we can sort of step back and
have that that flash where we're
suddenly confronted with the absurdity
why am I so happy about this what's
going on here is this really that
important of a thing you know could
happen while we're out with people at a
party it could happen while we're
thinking we're gonna enjoy something and
we suddenly find it absurd but how to
happiness in the absurd fit in here with
this story about Sisyphus and his status
as an absurd hero for us well there's a
sort of progression here narrative
progression that that Camus tells us
about first a character thrown into a
situation like that is going to be in
sorrow they're like this sucks
fate is crap then why the hell do I get
this and they go through that passion
but at a certain point acceptance come
and this is not an acceptance that's a
mere resignation you know shrinking your
shoulders in and saying well I guess I
gotta put up with this are you kiss I
don't deserve any better it's it's all
garbage and nothing is good for anybody
no it's not anything like that
it's an acceptance that says yeah this
sucks this is unfair but it's life so
I'm going to choose a different attitude
and he talks not just about Sisyphus in
this case but also about Oedipus who you
know had a terrible terrible run of
things and even after his gorgeous eyes
out after discovering that he killed his
father and married his mother and
engendered a bunch of kids of whom he's
also the uncle and the the the brother
right that's kind of a bad turn of
affairs he also can find a certain
possibility for joy in saying
nevertheless all is well
so how can this be the case there's
really a couple important conditions
here that Camus thinks are involved in
this character of Sisyphus and involved
in the absurd hero or the absurd person
in our own time so he says that all is
not all has not been exhausted
everything isn't just because things are
absurd everything isn't used up
everything isn't without value
altogether it's up to us to give things
value and he talks about in this case
the gods no longer being the ones who
run the show right it drives out of this
world of God who had come into it with
dissatisfaction and a preference for
futile sufferings it makes a fate a
human matter which must be settled among
men and he goes on and he talks about
Sisyphus and he says all of Sisyphus is
silent joy is contained there and his
fate belongs to him it's something that
is his rock is his thing likewise when
the absurd man contemplating his torment
silences all the idols and then he says
in the universe suddenly restored to
silence the myriad wandering little
voices of the earth rise up unconscious
secret calls invitation from all the
faces they are the necessary reverse and
the price of victory when we look at the
world no longer expecting all this grand
meaning out of it no longer expecting it
to make sense
it turns out there's still things in it
and those things still matter they don't
matter in the grand sense you know with
a capital M but they do matter they are
real and for Sisyphus it's his rock for
us it's whatever else that we are still
encountering in this existence so he
talks about a universe without masters
and this is a wonderful idea that he has
here he talks about
the fact that there is a universe
without master doesn't mean that there
isn't any possible meaning for us right
if there's if there is a personal faith
there is no higher destiny or at least
there is but one which Sisyphus
concludes is inevitable and despicable
for the rest he knows himself to be the
master of his days so each of us is
really the master of our days even if
we're caught in Labour's that seem
futile and hopeless and meaningless so
this is why he concludes with that
famous line that has been used so many
times and in so many ways with very
different meanings one must imagine
Sisyphus happy notice he doesn't say we
must conclude from a logical
argumentation that Sisyphus is happy he
doesn't tell us all that much about what
that happiness consists in that's up to
us to carry out with the act of the
imagination and it's up to us whether we
want to apply this lesson within the
scope of our own existence
you